so I'm here with Amy Jarek who's the
director of admissions at the University
of California at Berkeley and my
question to you is you know when you
when you imagine college admissions is
traditional notion of you get a GPA and
a certain type so you know you have to
take certain classes and all of these to
be quote-unquote qualified is that
always the case or is there a path for
students who might not have a
traditional GPA or might not have all
the traditional classes so I would say
that particularly in selective
admissions our job is not so much to
focus on the admit rate and what those
numbers look like when you look at the
incoming profile much more to think
about who's the student is going to
graduate successfully from our
institution and I think if we're doing
our job well we're finding those
students and it means that to keep up
with the way students learn today we
have to look beyond those traditional
measures so we do look past GPAs and
look beyond test scores we don't in
terms of the tools that we use we
probably haven't tapped into the very
best ones available yet but we do read
their writing and we look to see what if
extracurriculars are part of there's
never going to be a personal statement
or an essay that Trump's the academic
work
really it's thinking about academically
are you prepared for a classroom like
the one at Berkeley or the one in
Virginia or the one at Stanford right to
make sure that you'll succeed when
you're there I think for us we really
have started to see students who are
branching out and learning in different
ways and they're leading us right we're
having to figure out the ways to
evaluate and we don't have a whole lot
of experience we certainly have a whole
whole group of schools in the Northeast
that are some of our oldest secondary
schools who haven't given a letter grade
and that's fine we work with those we
always have we've worked with homeschool
students who typically bring us a
different kind of high school record so
we're learning but I do think that the
process of changing secondary age
kitchen is slowly also changing what we
will get and how we evaluate for success
once you get onto our campus so how do
you mention academics are very important
and completely understand that but how
would you evaluate someone's academic
potential if they don't have a
traditional GPA so a lot of what we're
gonna rely on the school to provide is
something that articulates in words or
numbers
letters whatever it is the type of
environment the student is learning in
what the core mastery is supposed to be
and then just helping us understand the
evaluation scale and what where does the
student fall on that scale and I think
sometimes that could be in the form of a
paragraph sometimes it may be in the
form of a chart I bet it's not it's not
what we do now is really we read within
context so it's not crazy to think that
we have to investigate the way of school
teachers before we can make the very
best decisions about how the student
learns in that school and that's
something that we just it's our
responsibility to do we're not in the
business of building secondary school
curriculums right we just need to learn
what type of curriculum you have and how
its articulated to us in terms of the
measurement of success so y'all look at
y'all take a closer look or as much
context you can have on that particular
school that might be in some ways not
traditional and then there's also things
like standardized tests that you could
sure so we have standardized tests that
not all universities and colleges that
use selective admissions look for
standardized tests anymore but most
still do and they are in most cases
they're simply validating something else
we see in the application though I mean
they're not for most schools they're not
the decision maker they're showing us
that oh look this student is strong in
math let's look at the SAT yep turns out
they're strong enough great there's no
big surprise every once in a while
there's a gap and that sometimes leads
to really good conversations in our own
environment about why that happens
is it test prep is it test anxiety or
you know we have a Provost at Berkeley
who's worked quite strongly and talking
about the stereotypes threats and the
whole idea that when you walk into a
space someone has already prejudged the
way you behave and standardized test is
usually the the lab they use to show
that so we we talk about that when
there's a gap but usually Saturdays has
just validates what we see and elsewhere
in that academic profile of the student
and there are these notions of approved
curricula or correct me if I'm wrong
especially here in California I think
there's some things that even a to be or
there's some date of G in a to G well
what are those things and and how how
strictly are those enforces it you you
have to somehow align to that sure so
the university system in California is
really aligned and it's been the line
through the master plan that was
developed in the 60s to be able to allow
students to build a path in and stay in
California starting in the secondary
school and moving up so the UC system as
the most selective public school system
in the state is looking to make sure
that the curriculum in the high school
is allowing the student to get the best
prep to do that the UC system for years
has actually evaluated the curriculum of
the high school so a high school if they
come up with a new course they need to
submit it to the UC system to get
approval and then when the application
is being filled out by the student
they'll see that course as you see
approved do we admit students from
schools that don't have use the approved
coursework absolutely I mean think about
all of the out-of-state students that
are applying none of them have UC
approved coursework right so we are
certainly thinking outside of that A
through G box but we use the A through G
language to help people understand what
the college prep path in California
looks like and the only way we can make
sure it's consistent is
having a system that evaluates each
course so that there's a bit like
standardized testing right there's
something about it that feels
standardized so that you can trust it a
little bit more yeah and just to and you
have it as you mentioned it could be
out-of-state students who obviously
weren't participating in this the ADA G
requirements and some of those might
even be non-traditional right of course
might not have a traditional GPA yeah I
think that you know and we also see a
lot of students now that one of the
hardest questions particularly for
students out of state I think right now
and they think about A through G it
includes art so if your student who is
incredibly interested and being admitted
to one of Berkeley's stem programs
particularly engineering you have the
opportunity to take a second year of
physics at an advanced level or complete
the A through G requirements by taking
art what am I supposed to say I want you
to take the physics right I want you to
have that background I believe in art of
course I do
I know why it's a part of energy but for
that students development and that
students interest that a through G
equation just doesn't fit and I think
that that's part of why we're you know
as we adjust to see what students are
learning and how they're learning and
what are the topics that are most
interesting to them we're just evolving
in the admissions process to be able to
meet them where they are and I'll be
honest a little behind right there
plenty of schools that challenge us with
the way that they teach or what they're
teaching but when those students come to
our campus as admitted students they
choose to attend they're the ones who go
to faculty hours they're the ones who
understand the value of having lab time
and doing hands-on activities and
research and I think that's a really
important part of the college experience
I don't have to spend quite as much time
building up that confidence level and
whether
not they should go talk to the Nuge or
whether or not they could possibly
participate in hands-on learning and so
your general sense it obvious it's hard
to make you know over broad statements
but a student non-traditional school or
background maybe doesn't have
traditional GPA but they're able to show
that their academic capabilities maybe
through standardized tests or they take
some other types of exams they can show
that they are of the caliber that y'all
would expect that they could come and do
well in a place like Berkeley and they
also show other things you know they
made cool projects or they have you know
really great portfolios of work that's
something that y'all take a serious look
at yeah I mean we would want from
through our process we actually asked
the student to articulate that so in
their personal statement they might talk
about an internship that they had and
why it mattered and what they did other
schools actually might have a letter of
recommendation process or a portfolio
review process where they'll look at the
things that were developed or they'll
hear the voice of the person who was
this individual supervisor or mentor and
I think that's an important piece of any
type of less than traditional model
because relying on a student who has
only known that model to explain
everything that's unique and cool about
it doesn't make a lot of sense right you
need someone from the outside
perspective to be able to compare and
contrast to maybe the way that they were
educated and understanding that students
story is very different and very
powerful in a modern way yeah well thank
you so much this is really value yeah of
course
have it out